Tenemos - 3/4 - 7/6 - 3/6. Hay
muchas formas de resolver esto,
pero de inmediato me doy cuenta de que estos dos
últimos números tienen un 6 en el denominador,
así que voy a trabajar primero con estos y
los voy a analizar como -7/6 - 3/6. Entonces,
si tenemos 7/6 - 3/6 será lo mismo que -7 -3
/ 6, y por supuesto tenemos este -3/4 que está
antes y que sumaremos a lo que obtengamos aquí.
Estos son estos dos términos que estoy sumando:
-7 - 3 es -10, -10 / 6, y luego vamos a sumarlo a
-3/4. Y ahora tengo que encontrar un denominador
común. ¿Cuál es el número más pequeño que es
múltiplo de 4 y 6? Bueno, puede que te salte
a la vista que es 12. Literalmente puedes repasar
los múltiplos de 4 o puedes mirar la factorización
prima de ambos números y encontrar el número
más pequeño que tenga todos los factores primos
de ambos. Entonces necesitas dos 2 y necesitas
un 2 y un 3, entonces si tienes dos 2 y un 3,
eso es 4 x 3, que es 12. Así que reescribamos esto
como algo entre 12 más otro algo entre 12. Bueno,
en este caso, para pasar el denominador de 4 a 12
tengo que multiplicarlo por 3, así que multiplico
también el numerador por 3, si multiplicamos 3
negativo por 3 nos da un -9. Y por acá, para pasar
el denominador de 6 a 12, tenemos que multiplicar
por 2, así que también tenemos que multiplicar el
numerador por 2 para que no cambie el valor de la
fracción. Entonces eso será 20 negativo, y ahora
estamos listos para sumarlos. El denominador común
es 12, y entonces serán 9 negativo + 20 negativo,
que escribo como -20 / 12. Y ahora, con redoble
de tambores, tenemos que es igual a -29 / 12,
y 29 es un número primo, por lo que
no va a compartir ningún factor común,
además de 1 con el 12, así que también
tenemos esto en su forma más simplificada.